You can tell me what you think about this,
but this is a statistic that just absolutely shocked and staggered me when I
went through the Intel intelligence literature.
So you know,
it is illegal in the United States to induct anybody who has an Iq of less than
83 and the reason for that is you know that the American armed forces have been
conducting intelligence research for like more than a hundred years.
And that was partly because they needed a way of sorting people rapidly during
times of military expansion during war time.
But it was also because I,
qts and especially in the early part of the 20th century,
were used to identify,
let's say the deserving poor who could really benefit from additional
educational attainment and advancement and the unit and the military was hoping
to identify people from nor class strata that could be a streamed into say,
officer training programs and so forth or,
or even skills training programs to,
to move people from the underclass into at least the working class and may be
above.
So they had a bloody stake in this man.
They wanted to find people,
they want it to sort them properly and they wanted to do social good when they
weren't just trying to win a war,
let's say,
which often also is a social good.
But what happened was that by,
I don't remember when this legislation was introduced,
but it wasn't,
it was in the later part of the 20th century,
but their basic finding was that by say the 1980s they had determined that if
you had an Iq of less than 83 there was not a damn thing that the unit that the
army could do,
the armed forces could do to transform you into someone who could do something
that was more productive than non productive.
And at the thera terrible thing about that is that it's about 10% of the
population.
And so you look at a statistic like that and you think,
oh my God,
you've got this is this is enterprise,
this massive enterprise that's chronically hungry for people.
It's right.
It's always,
they're always looking for people.
They're really oriented towards taking people from the underclass and lower
working class and pushing them up.
The societal strata and during wartime,
they're actually desperate to bring in recruits,
period.
And their conclusion is that 10% of the population can't be trained to do
anything,
anything sufficiently useful to make them militarily operable.
It's just,
I just read out,
my jaw just dropped.